>> Juan: PRINCE HARRY IS NOT A
FAN OF THE FIRST AMENDMENT IN
AMERICA.
THE ROYAL TAKING ISSUE WITH THE
PAPARAZZI AND THE QUOTE "FEEDING
FRENZY" WHEN HE ARRIVED IN
LOS ANGELES WITH HIS WIFE,
MEGHAN MARKLE.
>> I DON'T WANT TO GO DOWN THE
FIRST AMENDMENT ROAD.
ONE THING THAT I DON'T
UNDERSTAND.
BUT YOU CAN FIND A LOOP HOLE IN
ANYTHING.
YOU CAPITALIZE OR EXPLOIT WHAT
IS NOT SAID RATHER THAN WHAT IS
SAID.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND IT.
IT'S BONKERS.
>> Juan: SO JESSE, YOU THINK HE
HAS SOME ANGER ISSUES WITH THE
PRESS?
MAYBE UNDERSTANDABLY.
HIS MOTHER WAS FLEEING THE
PAPARAZZI WHEN SHE DIED, RIGHT?
>> Jesse: WELL, IF HE THINKS THE
FIRST AMENDMENT IS BONKERS, WAIT
TILL HE HEARS ABOUT THE SECOND
ONE.
[LAUGHTER]
IS HE A MEMBER OF THE ROYAL
FAMILY?
I DIDN'T THINK ROYALS WERE
ALLOWED TO COMPLAIN?
NOBODY ELSE IN HIS FAMILY
COMPLAINS ABOUT ANYTHING EXCEPT
THE CLIMATE, I GUESS.
WHY IS HE TALKING SO MUCH?
KEEP IT INSIDE A LITTLE BIT.
SEE A SHRINK.
DON'T DO EVERY INTERVIEW.
HE'S LIKE FAUCI.
HE DID A DAX SHEPHERD PODCAST?
HE WAS JUST ON OPRAH.
YOU CAN SAY NO TO DAX SHEPHERD'S
PODCAST.
MY GOD.
NOW HE SAYS OH, WE DIDN'T REALLY
LEARN THAT MUCH ABOUT THE FIRST
AMENDMENT IN SCHOOL.
WE LEARNED ABOUT GREAT BRITAIN.
WE GO OVER THERE, PLAY ALONG AND
BOW AND DO THE WHOLE THING.
HE NEVER LEARNED ABOUT THE
REVOLUTIONARY WAR?
THEY NEVER OUGHT TO THAT?
I'M GOING TO SEND HIM A COPY OF
"KILLING ENGLAND", JUAN.
>> Juan: SO GREG, WE HAVE
LIMITED.
YOU CAN'T SLANDER AND LIBEL
PEOPLE.
IS HE RIGHT THERE?
>> Greg: WE CAN.
HAPPENS EVERY DAY.
I DON'T KNOW IF I CAN DO BETTER
THAN WHAT JESSE JUST SAID.
THE GUY CLAIMS THAT HE HATES THE
PRESS AND PAPARAZZI.
SO I KNOW WHAT I'LL DO.
I'LL MOVE TO HOLLYWOOD WITH A
FAME HUNGRY ACTRESS.
THAT IS NOT FLEEING PAPARAZZI.
THEY KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THEY'RE
DOING.
HE KIND OF LOOKS -- I THINK --
TO HIS DEFENSE, HE'S DESCRIBING
THE FIRST AMENDMENT AS AN ODDITY
THAT IS UNIQUE TO AMERICA, THE
SAME WAY WE LOOK AT BRITISH
TEETH.
>> Juan: SO DANA, WHY DO WE
CARE?
>> Dana: WELL, HE'S MAKING US
CARE.
IF YOU'RE A BRITISH PERSON -- I
LIVE WITH ONE -- AND YOU COME TO
THE COUNTRY AND YOU SAY I DON'T
UNDERSTAND THIS WHOLE FIRST,
SECOND AMENDMENT THING, THIS
FREEDOM THING.
IF YOU'RE GOING ON A PODCAST OR
OPRAH AND YOU START THE SENTENCE
WITH I REALLY DON'T WANT TO GO
DOWN THE ROAD OF TALKING ABOUT
THE FIRST AMENDMENT BECAUSE I
DON'T KNOW ENOUGH ABOUT IT, STOP
THERE.
DON'T SAY ANYTHING ELSE.
LET ME GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE,
PRINCE.
FOR EXAMPLE, OUR FIRST
AMENDMENT, THE DUCHESS CAN
SLANDER AN ENTIRE ROYAL FAMILY
WITH RACISM.
>> Greg: EXACTLY.
>> Dana: GUESS WHAT?
THERE'S NO CONSEQUENCES FOR
THAT.
EVERYBODY IN MALIBU AND ALL OF
THE YOUNG PEOPLE THAT WANT TO
THINK OH, WOW, THAT IS SO GREAT.
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
THE FIRST AMENDMENT CAN PROVIDE.
>> Juan: YEAH, PROTECTS THEM.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS, DAGEN,
YOU THINK WE DEFER AND PROTECT
THE ROYAL FAMILY VERSUS
REFERRING TO HARRY AND MEGHAN?
>> Dagen: I DON'T WHAT?
WHAT?
I LOOK AT HARRY AND I THINK THE
ONLY THING THAT HE CAN SAY THAT
IS POSITIVE IS I'M NOT AS ODIUS
AS PRINCE ANDREWS.
HE'S THE GUY THAT COMES UP WITH
A ROLL OF MASKING TAPE AND
POMEGRANATE.
HE'S USELESS.
BUT HE'S GOOD ON OPRAH AND
EXERCISING THAT FIR